[Musique]
annulé l'année dernière à cause du coc
vite 19 le salon international de
l'agriculture se tiendra cette année du
26 février au 6 mars plusieurs
producteurs yvelinois et seront présents
nous sommes allés à leur rencontre
installé à côté de plaisir au coeur de
la plaine de versailles la femme de
grignon à plus de 100 ans créée en 1919
par des anciens élèves de l'institut
national agronomique
elle disposait d'environ 100 hectares
essentiellement dédié à la culture
aujourd'hui l'exploitation des pentes
d'agroparistech et s'étend sur 400
hectares avec 200 vaches laitières 600
brebis et une maîtrise ici à la fin de
grignon qu'à une exploitation de
polyculture élevage transforme sur plate
700 mille litres de lait tous les ans en
produits frais lait crème fraîche yorker
et depuis 2006 l'exploitation s'est
engagé à réduire sa consommation
d'énergie et sa production de gaz à
effet de serre chaque année on mesure
notre performance environnementale nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
d'année en année on cherche à
s'améliorer et donc on a réduit à peu
près notre impact environnemental de 30
% depuis 2006 ça passe par des
changements de culture des changements
de pratiques culturales des changements
de pratiques aussi sur les animaux
optimisé l'alimentation des animaux pour
trouver des aliments moins polluants
l'arrêt du soja par exemple au profit du
tourteau de colza d'origine française la
ferme de grignon abrite une berge vie
avec près de 600 brebis de race
berrichonne et romane et cette année
plusieurs bélier et agnel seront
présentés au salon de l'agriculture
d'accord on a une agnelle à une des
trois agnel qui vont être présentés sur
le salon de l'agriculture elle a 12 mois
actuellement elle est normalement
présumé gestantes en en présence de la
race romane une des deux races que nous
avons sur la ferme
la deuxième étant la berrichonne étant
présent dans la génétique de la roma a
été créée dans les années 70 par
croisements génétiques entre la
berrichonne donc races françaises
bouchehr et la roma n'a qu'une race
russe qui est race très prolifique donc
on est entré dans une race qui à la fois
des caractéristiques bouchehr et des
caractéristiques de prolificité
une vache prim'holstein sera également
présentée par des étudiantes
d'agroparistech pour le trophée
international de l'enseignement agricole
au concours dure quatre jours on a
quatre épreuves on a une épreuve de
manipulation
on doit en fait le but c'est de bien
appréhender lavage cette manière
par en respectant les règles de sécurité
âgée de trois ans et demi au l'un d'eux
sera face à une cinquantaine de vaches
elle a des caractéristiques de la vache
quand il ya des caractéristiques
morphologiques au niveau du pis
[Musique]
la ligne de dos sic et ses prises en
compte et après aussi les aplombs de
l'animal qui soit c'est l'orientation
des membres arrivé en deuxième position
en 2019 la ferme de grignon va tout
faire pour monter sur la première marche
du podium cette année
[Musique]